gas prices have come down substantially
over the past few months from over five
dollars per gallon to just under four
dollars per gallon now of course four
dollars per gallon is still
significantly higher than where we were
just a year ago but it is nonetheless
till progress from five dollars per
gallon time the average gas price in New
York state has hit the five dollar per
gallon Mark in New Jersey it is now five
dollars and three cents this has caused
many to assume the supply chain issues
have been resolving it and that
inflation has been cooling down and
while these factors definitely do play a
role one of the most blatant reasons for
the recent decrease is oil stimulus from
the US you see it the U.S department of
energy likes to keep a backup or Reserve
called the U.S strategic petroleum
Reserve this Reserve is meant for
serious emergencies like the US getting
into a war or the Middle East staging a
strike but since March of this year the
US has been using these reserves to
alleviate gas prices whether this is a
justifiable reason it is debatable but
one thing that's for sure is that the US
has been depleting these reserves fast I
could go through the specific numbers
and we will later on in the video but I
think just looking at this chart will
tell you everything you need to know so
how much longer do we have until the US
depletes their backup Reserves
to estimate how much time we have left
the easiest thing to do would be to
calculate the average rate of decline it
and use that to project into the future
if you zoom into the chart you'll see
that the cliff dive really started in
April of 2022 when the reserve stood at
568 million barrels of oil if we
scrolled October however the reserves
are estimated to stand at just 359
million barrels that right there is not
only a 40 or low in terms of reserves
but also a record pace of decline during
this six-month period the us would have
used up 209 million barrels of Reserve
oil that translates to an average of
about 35 million barrels per month at
that rate the reserves would only last
for another 10 months taking us to about
August of next year but if we look
closer at the data we'll see that we
don't have nearly that much time here's
the thing not all crude oil is created
equal and the US doesn't just store one
type of crude oil they actually store
two types called the medium sour and
light sweet to the naked eye both of
these would look the same as the
differences are mainly internal medium
sour oil has a higher density and a
higher sulfur content which is what the
world has become accustomed to this is
the type of oil that is pumped out by
Russia Venezuela and much of the Middle
East and this is also the type of oil
that the U.S refiners are used to as
well given that refiners are currently
the biggest bottleneck in the oil Market
the US has leaned into their needs in
other words the vast majority of oil the
US has been unloading as an 85 percent
is a medium sour crude oil this means
that out of the 35 million barrels that
they were offloading every month roughly
30 million barrels were sour and 5
million were sweet this wouldn't be that
big of a problem if medium sour
accounted for 85 percent of their
reserves but it doesn't according to the
government's website forty percent of
the reserves were sweet and sixty
percent were sour as of the beginning of
2022 if we assume that this ratio was
more or less maintained chained until we
saw the cliff dive in April we started
with roughly 340 million barrels of sour
oil and 227 million barrels of sweet oil
at a rate of 30 million barrels of sour
oil and a 5 million barrels of wheat oil
every month will be left with
approximately 160 million barrels of
sour oil and 197 million barrels of
sweet oil by October if we don't change
up our rate of consumption or ratio of
consumption the sour oil reserves will
be gone by March as for the sweet oil
reserves we'll still have plenty of that
but that probably wouldn't be all that
helpful here's the thing when you have a
refining bottleneck with sweet oil
pumping up the supplier won't actually
lead to more final output also it's
unlikely that refiners will be willing
to expand their light speed operations
all that much when this is just a
temporary influx of sweet oil so the
countdown has already started and it's
just a matter of months until the us
will have to pull the plug
foreign
you might be thinking that this was a
nice thing for the government to do they
finally stepped up and took action
against oil prices that were spiraling
it out of control while this could be
their reasoning it's probably not the
case you see it the US never Taps into
this oil Reserve looking at this graph
you can see that the reserves are always
stagnating or going up this is literally
the first time the US has been depleting
at spr reserves it since it was created
way back in 1975. they didn't even
deplete the reserves in 2008 when the US
saw a massive recession and oil prices
at over a hundred and eighty dollars per
barrel so clearly they're more desperate
than ever before and why are they more
desperate than ever before well its
biggest inflation is way out of control
and it's making the incumbent
politicians look incompetent right
before the midterm elections and that
right there is the key to everything
they've been doing all obviously there's
nothing that politicians can do to bring
down inflation to three percent or solve
the supply shortage within the next two
months but something they can do it is
deplete the emergency or reserves to
create the impression that inflation is
coming down here's the thing the average
person that doesn't actually follow CPI
readings on a monthly basis their gauge
of inflation is simply based on how much
their daily and the monthly expenses are
if they suddenly go to the pump one day
and their bill is ten dollars lower than
usual they're going to assume that
inflation is getting better and it's not
just the pump that they'll see this
difference either when you bring down
oil prices you bring down prices across
the board because almost all everyday
Goods rely on Transportation take milk
for example milk is still super
expensive on a historical basis but
prices have stopped going up since May
we don't know how much of this is
actually due to oil prices coming down
but one thing's for sure they're
definitely trying the only problem
though is that all the signs point to
them stopping trying it right after the
elect action is over take the oil
depletion for example if the rate of
depletion was 15 or 20 million barrels
of oil per month we could come to the
conclusion that maybe it's more of a
long-term plan this page would actually
be sustainable for a few years which
might be enough time for all prices to
naturally cool down but with a depletion
rate of 35 million barrels per month and
sour oil reserves being projected to run
out by Q2 of next year it's hard to
believe that this is anything but a
short-term political play it seems like
they want to bring down oil prices as
much as possible before the election but
after the election it doesn't seem like
they'll care all that much even if they
did care and it's not like they could do
anything about it given that the oil
reserves would already be nearly
depleted so in my opinion I think it's
highly likely that they Rock plus
shortly after the election but I'll let
you be the judge of that
foreign
just one big political move or not in
the end it it doesn't really matter
either way we end up in the same
destination which is depleted at
emergency or reserves so what happens
next well fortunately for us the US
Department of Treasury has done some
studies regarding how the emergency
reserves are affecting gas prices to
accomplish this they looked at data
regarding the stock of oil and the flow
of oil now of course no model is perfect
and that applies to the U.S treasury as
well for example in their calculations
they assume that there is zero
elasticity on the supply side similarly
they also assume that logistical and
technical issues it can be ignored given
how bad the supply chain has been over
the past two years these assumptions are
obviously not super realistic but it's
the best that we've got according to the
study yet the release of American oral
reserves has resulted in a price
reduction of 33 cents per gallon
something that we should note is that it
wasn't just that you worst I was
depleting their oil reserves when
President Biden announced his plans to
leverage American reserves he also got
Partners in the iea or the International
Energy agency to play along together
it's estimated that they've brought down
all prices by approximately 38 cents per
gallon so simple logic tells us that
when these organizations stop injecting
oil into the system gas prices should go
up by 38 cents but it's obviously not
that simple if oil prices naturally cool
down by this point then maybe we can see
all prices continue to Trend down it
even after these guys would throw out
their support this would be the most
ideal situation and hopefully it's what
happened if oil prices are still at
relatively high levels however we could
use lazy oil prices like by much more
than 38 cents because we would no longer
have a safety net all suppliers will be
well aware that the US can't pull off
this stunt again so they might have even
more pricing power than they had it
before this Fiasco the country that
America would really have to worry about
is not Saudi Arabia or some other Middle
Eastern country they would actually have
to worry about Canada most people don't
know this but Canada is actually
America's number one source of imported
oil literally 62 percent of U.S crude
oil imports comes from Canada so they
have quite a bit of power fortunately
the US and Canada are pretty good allies
so it's extremely unlikely that Canada
would do anything to destroy America for
example they're not going to stop all
exports altogether and watch as gas
prices shoot up to 30 per gallon in
America but just because they won't do
something so drastic it does not mean
that they'll be gracious with the
pricing especially when you consider
that America has never been gracious
with Canada you see it Canada actually
has the third largest oil reserves in
the entire world but they've never
really been able to leverage this to
become a global player if you're
interested in why I have a full video
about Canada's oil situation but long
story short Canada has basically been
forced into a situation where 99 percent
of their oil end up in the North
American Market or basically just
America and this has given the US the
opportunity to essentially blackmail
Canada into giving them cheap oil now
argument from the US is usually we have
these massive Reserves at as well as
sources from Russia and the Middle East
so we don't need you you need us so if
you want us to buy your oil give us a
discount and that's exactly what
Canada's been doing with the average
discount on Canadian Oil being 20 per
barrel
now the table as I've turned the
emergency reserves are rapidly depleting
and Russia is out of the equation so
Canada has the upper hand and honestly
after getting taken advantage of for so
many decades I think it's only fair that
Canada gets to turn the script on the
U.S but let's just say it won't be very
fun for our pocketbooks
foreign
if you've been wondering why gas prices
have been plummeting over the past few
months it's not because inflation is
coming down it's actually because the
government has essentially been handing
out gas stimulus from their emergency
Reserves at the current rate however
they won't be able to sustain the
stimulus for much longer but honestly
that seems to have been their plan all
along cool down gas prices before the
election as much as possible and will
worry about the rest later in the medium
tournament this may end up giving Canada
more pricing power than ever allowing
them to finally have some time in the
spotlight at the expense of everyday
Americans again I wouldn't blame Canada
for this but rather American politicians
for putting America in such a situation
but that's just what I think do you
think it was justified to leverage the
emergency oil reserves comment that down
below also drop a like if you wish
politicians didn't just care about
elections and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggested video ideas and instead of
subscribe and see more questions at
logical answer but until then I'm party
and I'll see you guys on the next one